hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mo und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
hallo mein Name ist Natalie Strauß ich
bin Radiomoderatorin und mit mir am
Mikrofon ist Sprecher Mirko Kasimir
hallo hi grüß Dich Natalie schön wieder
hier bei dir zu sein wir erzählen euch
hier von Verbrechen aus Vergangenheit
und Gegenwart die uns und viele andere
noch immer beschäftigen auch wenn sie
schon lange zurückliegen und heute geht
es um einen der mysteriösesten Morde der
deutschen Kriminalgeschichte ein Fall
der unsere Vorstellungskraft an ihre
Grenzen bringt der Horrorfilme und
Verschwörungstheorien inspiriert hat der
Mordfall hinter kaifeck Mirko was ist
hinter kein Weg und worum geht's hier
hinter kaifeck war ein Einödhof in der
Nähe des Dorfes Gröbern in Oberbayern in
der Nacht vom 31 März auf den ersten
April 1922 wurden dort sechs Menschen
ermordet alle Bewohner von Hinterkaifeck
dieser Begriff an sich jagt mir schon
und Schauer über den Rücken Einöd hoch
da habe ich sofort Nebel Kalle Bäume und
so ein ziemlich heruntergekommenes Haus
vor Augen also nicht wirklich ein Ort
zum glücklich sein ein Ort zum Fürchten
ja das wohl eher aber vielleicht kommen
diese Gedanken auch daher dass ich
diesen Fall kenne Einöd hoch bezeichnet
keine Einöde sondern einfach nur ein
einzeln stehendes Haus oder ein Hof der
jetzt nicht unbedingt zu einer Ortschaft
gehört das war früher übrigens nichts
besonderes und an sich keinen Grund zum
Fürchten also jetzt nicht unbedingt wie
im Horrorfilm Text das chains Massaker
falls ihr den gesehen habt und sicher
war es da auch nicht andauernd nebelig
auf dem Hof Hinterkaifeck Leben Cäcilia
und Andreas Gruber 72 und 64 Jahre alt
deren verwitwete Tochter Victoria
Gabriel 35 Jahre alt und deren sieben
und dreijährige Kinder Cecilia und Josef
am 31 März einem Freitag trifft außerdem
Maria Baumgartner ein 45 Jahre alt die
in Zukunft als Markt auf dem Hof
arbeiten und leben soll
keiner von ihnen wird die folgende Nacht
überleben
am 2 April fehlt Familie Gruber Gabriel
beim allsun-täglichen Gottesdienst in
der Pfarrkirche Maria Reinigung und St
Wendelin in Waidhofen
es ist nicht so dass man sich sonderlich
vermisst die hinterkaifecker gelten als
verschrobene Einsiedler und werden als
geizig geschmeckt Reich sollen sie sein
von 100.000 Mark in Münzen fandbriefen
und Edelmetallen ist die Rede ganz zu
schweigen von ihrem großen Grundstück
und reichlich Vieh
also beliebt sind die Grubers nicht es
gibt auch Gerüchte Viktoria habe noch
Geschwister gehabt doch die Eltern
hätten sie vernachlässigt und sterben
lassen das sagt zum Beispiel ein
zeugennamens Lorenz Schlittenbauer aus
von dem gleich noch ausführlicher die
Rede sein wird er gibt folgendes zu
Protokoll
die Kinder sind wohl alle gestorben weil
sie keine Pflege hatten und auch nicht
genügend ernährt wurden ich selbst und
auch mein Vater hatten öfters erlebt
dass die kleinen Kinder tagelang im
Keller bleiben mussten wenn man
Vorbeigehen hätte man die Kinder im
Keller weinen ich sag's ganz offen die
Leute waren nicht gut da hat der
Herrgott schon die rechte Hand am
rechten Platz gehabt
okay das ist unvorstellbar ich meine
einerseits sind alle ganz schnell dabei
die Grubers zu verurteilen aber alle
müssen ja auch gewusst haben dass da was
vor sich geht und andererseits hat ja
niemand was unternommen ganz
offensichtlich natürlich gab es damals
auch keine Strukturen mit so etwas
umzugehen also ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass da vor 100 Jahren auf dem Dorf die
Devise galt und was der Nachbar macht
das geht mich nichts an da trat ich
lieber drüber aber einmischen nee das
sind mir persönlich die Liebsten
besonders viel geredet wird über
Victoria die junge Witwe ihr Mann vielem
Krieg er kann nicht der Vater ihres
kleinen dreijährigen sein
als Vater des Jungen das wissen sie alle
ist der Lorenz Schlittenbauer
eingetragen der Ortsvorsteher von
Gröbern
Neujahr er hat mit der Viktoria
geschlafen das gibt dazu
die Victoria Gabriel war überhaupt für
den Geschlechtsverkehr leicht zu haben
sagt er später in seiner Vernehmung und
er habe sie sogar heiraten wollen
doch dazu so hätten es Victoria und ihr
Vater verlangt habe er die Vaterschaft
anerkennen sollen obwohl doch alle
wüssten wer wahrscheinlich der wirkliche
Vater sei
niemand anders als der alte Gruber
Victorias Vater und damit gleichzeitig
Großvater und Vater des kleinen Josef
ihr fehlen beim Gottesdienst fällt
jedenfalls auf die Grubers mögen nicht
beliebt oder gottesfürchtig sein doch
trotz ihres Geistes haben Sie stets ihr
Scherflein beigetragen wenn die Kollekte
herum ging
die kleine die Cecilia war ja gestern
auch nicht in der Schule weiß eine der
Mütter aus Gröbern
die Kinder und der Lehrer haben dann für
ihre Gesundung gebetet
am dritten April fehlt Cecilia erneut
unentschuldigt in der Schule
ebenso am 4 April einem Dienstag für
diesen Tag ist der Mechaniker Albert
Hofner nach Hinterkaifeck bestellt er
soll den Motor der
futterschneidemaschine reparieren
doch niemand öffnet auf seinen klopfen
niemand reagiert auf seine Rufe
er schaut sich auf dem Hof und im Stall
um kann aber keine Spur der Familie
entdecken keine Spur der Grubers seltsam
ist außerdem dass das viel Wild an den
Ketten zieht und der Hund bellt
Hofner macht sich an die verabredete
Reparatur etwa viereinhalb Stunden
braucht er
dann verlässt er hinter kaifeck um ein
andermal wegen der Bezahlung
zurückzukommen in Gröbern trifft der
Mechaniker die Töchter von Lorenz
Schlittenbauer und erzählt von der
unheimlichen Lehre in Hinterkaifeck
Lorenz schickt seine Söhne hin um nach
dem Rechten zu sehen
die bestätigen hofnar Schilderung noch
am selben Tag macht sich Lorenz
Schlittenbauer mit zwei anderen Männern
nach Hinterkaifeck auf
sie dringen in die Gebäude ein
und finden das Grauen
die Leichen von Cecilia und Andreas
Gruber von Viktoria Gabriel und ihrer
Tochter Cecilia liegen im Stall sie sind
teilweise mit Stroh abgedeckt
den dreijährigen Josef findet meinem
Kinderwagen im Schlafzimmer seiner
Großeltern
die Leiche der dienstmarkt in ihrer
Kammer
alle sechs wurden erschlagen
das Vieh im Stall ist losgelassen und
das Haus durchwühlt
Lorenz Schlittenbauer schickt seine
Söhne los um die Polizei zu informieren
unterwegs berichten sie allen den sie
begegnen von der Tat und so finden sich
noch vor der Polizei zahlreiche
Schaulustige ein
die örtliche Polizei ist überfordert die
Polizei München wird zu Unterstützung
gerufen doch auch diese scheint auf ein
solches Verbrechen nicht vorbereitet zu
sein
es werden nur fünf Tatort Fotos gemacht
nachdem die Leichen schon bewegt wurden
und niemand nimmt Fingerabdrücke
auf einem improvisierten Seziertisch
werden die Toten gleich vor Ort
obduziert die Todesursache ist eindeutig
alle sechs wurden erschlagen mutmaßlich
mit einer kreuzhacke
besonders erschütternd die siebenjährige
Cäcilia hat nach dem letztlich tödlichen
Schlag noch etwa zwei Stunden gelebt und
sich im Todeskampf büschelweise Haare
ausgerissen
der oder die Täter müssen sich nach der
Tat noch lange auf dem Hof aufgehalten
haben die Kuh wurde gemolken ein
Schinken aus der Räucherkammer ist
frisch angeschnitten und Zeugen haben
zwischen dem ersten und vierten April
Rauch aus dem Kamin aufsteigen sehen
es gibt eine Menge Merkwürdigkeiten und
Ungereimtheiten kurz vor der Tat beklagt
der Andreas Gruber den Verlust seines
einzigen hausschlüssels außerdem sei in
letzter Zeit jemand auffällig um das
Haus herumgestrichen auf dem Dachboden
der vom Wohnhaus über den Stall und die
Scheune verläuft ist Heu ausgestreut als
habe jemand Schritte dämpfen wollen
zwei Dachziegel sind so verschoben dass
man vom Boden aus den gesamten Hof
überblicken kann jemand muss sich vor
kurzem ja aufgehalten haben das sieht
man auch an Mulden in einem Heuhaufen
sofort beginnt die Suche nach den Tätern
und nach dem Motiv
Polizei und Presse gehen anfangs von
Raubmord aus doch diese Theorie wird
bald angezweifelt
es wurde noch viel Bargeld gefunden
warum sollten die Räuber das liegen
lassen
Zeit zum Durchsuchen hatten sie genug
überhaupt wer würde nach einem Raubmord
noch zwei oder drei Tage am Tatort
verbleiben und spricht die Grausamkeit
des Verbrechens nicht eher für eine
Beziehungstat
schnell gerät Lorenz Schlittenbauer in
Verdacht er wohnt nur 350 Meter von
hinterkalfik entfernt und hatte alle
Möglichkeiten den Hof auszusperren und
unauffällig hin und herlaufen zu können
und dann ist da noch die Sache mit dem
Schlüssel als die Leichen aufgefunden
werden ist die Haustür verschlossen da
Stall und Haus verbunden sind dringt
Schlittenbauer durch den Stall ins Haus
vor und schließt dann von in die Tür auf
um seine Begleiter einzulassen
der Schlüssel habe innen im Schloss
gesteckt sagt er aber der alte Gruber
hatte ja eben jenen Schlüssel kurz zuvor
verloren auch kennt sie Schlittenbauer
merkwürdig gut auf dem Hof und im Haus
aus
kann es sein dass der Ortsvorsteher die
Familie getötet hat weil der alte Gruber
von ihm dem eingetragenen Vater des
kleinen Josef Unterhalt forderte nichts
davon kann bestätigt oder ausgeschlossen
werden noch heute gilt Schlittenbauer
vielen als der Hauptverdächtige
doch über einen Mangel an Theorien und
Verdächtigen kann die Polizei wahrlich
nicht klagen mehr als 100 Personen
werden zwischenzeitlich verdächtigt und
viele dieser Verdächtigen sind bis heute
nicht endgültig entlastet worden
da ist Karl Gabriel scheinbar der
Verdächtige mit dem allerbesten Alibi
Karl Gabriel ist tot er war Viktorias
Ehemann und starb auf den
Schlachtfeldern des Ersten Weltkriegs
doch immer wieder tauchen Gerüchte auf
er habe die Identität mit einem
gefallenen Kameraden getauscht
immer wieder tauchen Menschen auf die
die Geschichte bestätigen und behaupten
sie sein Gabriel begegnet
hat er aus Rache für den Inzest des
Schwiegervaters oder die Untreue der
Ehefrau die gesamte Familie ermordet
dann ist der Josef Bertl der kurz zuvor
aus einer Heilanstalt geflohen ist
der Verdacht ist auf Bertel gefallen
schreibt das Salzburger Volksblatt vom
22 April 1922 da man sich sagt ein
derart scheußliches Verbrechen können
nur ein Geisteskranker verüben
da sind die Gebrüder Gump die bereits in
Morde an Bauern in Oberschlesien
verwickelt gewesen sein sollen die
Brüder Schreier die als Tagelöhner in
der Gegend unterwegs sind und als
Gewalttätigkeit gelten da ist Anton
Pichler der rum erzählt haben soll dass
die hinterkaifecke alle erschlagen
gehören da ist naja ihr seht schon wohin
das führt ja jedenfalls nicht zu einer
Lösung oder gar Verurteilung die Polizei
versucht alles um den Fall aufzuklären
wirklich alles ein Hellseher meldet sich
sogar bei der Polizei und behauptet er
könne den Fall lösen alles was er dafür
brauche wären die Schädel der Opfer
und tatsächlich lässt die Polizei die
Schädel dahinter kein Wecker abtrennen
und nach Nürnberg bringen
kleiner Spoiler auch der Hellseher kann
in diesem Fall nicht helfen
auch die riesige Belohnung von 100.000
Mark bringt zwar viele Hinweise aber
keine Lösung
die schlampige Ermittlungsarbeit zu
Beginn der Untersuchung lässt sich nicht
wiedergutmachen
und so bleibt der Mordfall hinter kaifik
bis heute ungelöst und die Quelle von
Spekulationen Theorien und
Gruselgeschichten
apropos Gruselgeschichten dazu passen
ziemlich makaberes Detail die Toten
wurden auf dem Friedhof weithofen
bestattet ohne Schädel denn die sind
nach ihrem Ausflug zum Hellseher nämlich
nie wieder zurückgekehrt zuletzt
befanden sie sich in einem Justizgebäude
in Augsburg das bei einem Bombenangriff
im Zweiten Weltkrieg schwer getroffen
wurde die Schädel der sechs aus
Hinterkaifeck wurden dabei zerstört
von Tatort selbst ist nichts mehr zu
sehen der Hof wurde schon 1923
abgerissen nicht weiter von steht heute
ein Marder das ist so ein kleines
religiöses Denkmal auch heiligen Stock
oder wegstock genannt
viele Ermittlungsakten verbrannten
ebenfalls im Zweiten Weltkrieg
1955 wurden die Akten geschlossen doch
die letzte Vernehmung fand erst 1986
statt
ein Kriminalhauptkommissar ermittelte
noch im Ruhestand weiter
erst mit 83 Jahren schloss auch eher
seine Akten und gab sie an das
bayerische Polizeimuseum weiter
mal wieder einer dieser Fälle bei denen
wir euch die endgültige Klärung schuldig
bleiben müssen aber ich weiß nicht wie
es Dir geht Mirko das macht natürlich
auch ein Großteil dieser Faszination aus
auf jeden Fall und bei den Morden von
hinterkeifig da trifft das ganz
besonders zu denn die Umstände der Tat
die Familienverhältnisse das ganze
Setting das klingt schon alles irgendwie
wie die Blaupause für die Horrorversion
eines Heimatfilms ja genau das ist ja
auch der Grund irgendwie für meine
Faszination diese ganze Düsternis diese
Lebensumstände ja die wie anfangs schon
erwähnt diese Bilder die sich dafür
nicht aufdringt das einsame Gehöft im
Nebel von Bäumen umgeben blattlose essen
ja man kann sich da richtig schön rein
steigern aber am Ende des Tages tut mir
total leid für diese Familie ja auch
wenn sie da größtenteils ihr eigenes
hübschen gebracht haben aber das hat
wirklich keiner verdient auf so eine
brutale Art und Weise aus dem Leben
gerissen zu werden und ins weitere die
Kinder es ist einfach bis heute eine
unfassbar gruselige Geschichte ja und
Mirko wir sind am Ende unserer heutigen
Folge und ich glaube ich brauche jetzt
eine richtig schöne heiße Schokolade
oder irgendwas anderes das mir diese
Kälte die mir gefühlt so tief in den
Knochen sitzt verdrängt das seid ihr
gegönnt auf jeden Fall und auch euch
liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer falls ihr
Lust darauf habt wir danken euch fürs
zuhören und hoffen dass sie bei der
nächsten Folge wieder dabei seid bei
Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer Mirko
und eure Natalie
den mysteriösen Fall hinter kaifeck
haben wir euch anhand von Artikeln aus
dem Staatsarchiv München Wikipedia und
einem Bericht in der Salzburger wach
erzählt
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Heyer Produktion Marvin schwarz